we are literally going five rolls let's
go big or go home
[Music]
we have to wake up to murders every
morning they're talking about the serial
killer that's like basically in our
backyard it is so exciting
La it's brutal especially when you're
pushing 50. bartenders into you that's
like it'd be bartender's dad
did anyone catch my favorite murder
what do you even know about this guy
should I use protection or should he
just pull out you know if I end up on
Dateline I can leave a massive DNA Trail
for you True Crime weirdos
can't pay any of our bills and you just
lost your job we have a baby on the way
so tell me how are we going to get by
she is the victim of the West Side
Ripper it's him
I know my Killers but if we make a
podcast about this together we could
bring them in on it bring the killer in
on what the podcast we force them to do
it oh my God this is
no one ever went broke betting on
America's obsession with murder he'll
never hurt anyone ever again or we go to
the cops let's do this babe you're so
hot it's bad for the baby says actually
pull my hair come on baby
are you in danger
you really think he's gonna kill us
what do you know about the west side rip
We Are In Too Deep this is it we're
gonna have a baby in jail
we don't know what he's gonna do next no
I lied no I'm hiding something I love
him are you crazy
[Applause]
you want to come visit me in San Quentin
Midnight Express me under the table what
is that you know
I don't do that come on bad behavior
[Music]